Traductor: Katya Huici
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Los sueños se cumplen y por eso
yo estoy acá hoy.
Cuando yo aprendí a tocar guitarra
hace mucho de tiempo,
en vez de tratar de sacar la canción
que estaba de moda,
una canción que me gustaba,
empecé a crear mis propias melodías,
empecé a escribir mis propias canciones.
Era algo que me salía natural
y era muy muy satisfactorio
y desde entonces siento
una gran pasión por la música
y una gran admiración
por la actividad creativa y los creadores.
En aquel momento,
cuando yo estaba empezando
no había muchos lugares
en los cuales yo podía presentarme.
Conseguir teatros era algo
relativamente difícil
y lo único que tenía a mano
eran bares, boliches,
estos lugares no estaban necesariamente
bien acondicionados
para lo que yo quería hacer,
cuando había luces y sonido
generalmente eran insuficientes.
Además de eso, tenía que ser
el boletero, el barrendero, el productor,
el jefe de prensa, el manager, el contador
el vestuarista, el iluminador, en fin
cualquier persona que haya emprendido
sabrá de qué hablo cuando digo
que hay que hacer de todo,
todo al mismo tiempo.
Era difícil pero
yo me bajaba del escenario contento
porque estar en un escenario
me llena de alegría.
Sin embargo, siempre me quedaba la duda,
siempre había algo
que podría haber hecho mejor,
siempre había algo que podía
haber hecho de manera diferente,
incluso cuando empecé a tocar
en otras ciudades,
me di cuenta que la situación
era muy parecida en otros lugares
entonces salió mi primera conclusión:
había que crear más y mejores escenarios.
Un tiempo después,
con esa misma idea en mente
nos juntamos con un grupo
de gestores y artistas.
Creamos un colectivo al cual
muy creativamente le llamamos:
"El colectivo"
Entonces, empezamos a crear escenarios
tomamos el museo de arte,
tomamos plazas, parques,
todo los lugares que pudimos
y creamos escenarios
para los artistas locales
y los artistas nacionales,
nosotros incluidos, por supuesto.
La dinámica que se generó
fue tan linda que tuvo impacto
a nivel nacional; artistas de rock,
de pop, de funk, de rap
imagínense la cantidad
de géneros musicales,
tuvieron mayores oportunidades
de acceder a un escenario
y el público tenía mayor oportunidad
de conocernos a los artistas
y de seguir a quienes les gustaba.
Este trabajo lo hacíamos
usando fondos públicos
y desafortunadamente los recortes
de los presupuestos de cultura
poco a poco se fueron llevando
uno a uno estos proyectos
que fuimos creando.
El último espectáculo, el último show
que ofrecimos fue en febrero de 2016
después de 6 años de trabajo,
generando escenarios para artistas.
El final de esa etapa,
me dejó pensando en algo
que me venía dando vueltas en la cabeza
desde hace mucho tiempo.
¿Cómo alcanzamos la sostenibilidad?
es decir, habíamos creado escenarios
sin embargo eso no era suficiente,
nuestro colectivo dependía
económicamente de un tercero
que nos podía dejar colgados,
que fue finalmente lo que sucedió,
entonces estábamos a la deriva.
El desafío era probar
que la creatividad, el arte y la cultura
podían generar valor económico.
Obviamente yo se que a ustedes les dirán,
siempre nos han dicho a todos
que el arte no da,
que te vas a morir de hambre,
que la cultura, que no se puede,
que es dificil, en fin,
ese era el desafío;
probar que un emprendimiento
cultural, creativo, era viable,
en este ciudad y en este país.
Tiempo después, fue muy grato para mí
descubrir que había más gente
en esa sintonía.
En un concierto,
donde más podría haber sido,
conocí a unas personas,
empezamos a discutir, a charlar,
nos reunimos durante semanas
y después de un tiempo, nació Meraki.
Meraki es una palabra griega que significa
ponerle el alma a las cosas o imprimir
el alma en las cosas que uno hace.
Esta palabra no solo sirvió
de nombre para el proyecto
sino también sirvió como lema
para todos los que trabajamos en él.
El concepto no era nada novedoso,
los "Café-Concert o Café-Chantant"
como algunos les llaman
existen en Europa desde el siglo XVIII,
algunos dicen que hasta son anteriores
y en muchas ciudades del mundo,
son bastante comunes.
Sin embargo, lo que queríamos
era poner el escenario
a disposición de los artistas,
para que ellos puedan ofrecer
el show que siempre soñaron a su público
queríamos ser el semillero
para artistas nuevos,
ya no dependíamos de nadie,
ya no dependíamos de ningún tercero
podíamos hacer, deshacer y rehacer.
Sin embargo,
todos los que emprenden saben
que no solo de "ponerle el alma
a las cosas" se vive,
para que el proyecto tenga éxito,
tenía que ser también sostenible
vuelve el desafio.
Entonces empezamos
un proceso de fórmulas,
buscar la fórmula con la cual
la magia tenía que suceder
y creanme la magia también sucede,
tiene que suceder en la gestión.
Teníamos que buscar y encontrar la forma
en la cual el espacio tenía que funcionar
y que los artistas pudieran hacer
dibujo libre en nuestro escenario.
Las fórmulas fueron, vinieron,
todavía van y vienen
porque seguimos en un proceso
de experimentación,
pero había algo que siempre saltaba
a la vista en cada éxito y cada fracaso
teníamos que ser
cómplices de nuestros artistas
y los artistas tenían que ser
nuestros socios principales.
En esta complicidad-sociedad
nosotros hacíamos la gestión,
vendíamos las entradas,
hacíamos las reservas, organizabamos,
limpiabamos, coordinábamos
para que el espacio estuviera limpio,
operativo, preparado,
con el equipo técnico,
ya sea para ensayos, para montaje
o para la ejecución de un show,
para pruebas de sonido tambien, en fin,
hacíamos un poco de difusión también,
tratábamos de contactar con el público,
con los medios de prensa,
hacíamos todo ese trabajo
que para muchos de nosotros es invisible
pero es fundamental
para que un espectáculo funcione,
para que un espectáculo sea un éxito.
Esta complicidad hizo
que empezáramos a ampliar
las opciones de nuestro escenario.
Empezamos a recibir obras de teatro,
proyecciones de películas,
documentales, presentaciones de libros,
shows de comedia, en fin, muchas cosas
que nos hicieron descubrir
que en nuestra ciudad hay mucho talento
que está buscando escenarios,
hay mucha gente que quiere compartir
actividades culturales,
actividades creativas
y así, apareció un nuevo desafío.
Teníamos una gran variedad de actividades,
teníamos una gran variedad de propuestas,
pero la sala no estaba llena siempre.
Evidentemente, había algunos artistas
que fueron un éxito inmediato,
hubo otros que empezaron
a crecer y poco a poco
fuimos viendo, como evolucionaban
hasta llegar donde están ahora.
Y ahí es donde viene la parte
que le corresponde al artista
en esta sociedad-complicidad.
¿Qué debería hacer el artista
que tiene la sala llena?
En este tiempo hemos identificado
tres cosas que son sencillas
pero muy importantes:
Crear constantemente:
el artista que está creando constantemente
siempre puede arrancarle
un "WOW" a su público
y ese público, siempre va a querer volver
para dejarse sorprender.
Conectar con el público:
el artista que conecta con el público
tiene una convocatoria increíble,
el artista que conecta con el público sabe
cuales son las cosas
que le arrancan ese "WOW" al público
y trabaja sobre estas para
que el público vuelva,
para que el público siempre se sorprenda.
Y tres, esta es muy importante:
Aceptan y hacen
el trabajo que no les gusta
o la parte que no les gusta de su trabajo.
Uds. saben que todos los trabajos
tiene su "lado oscuro"
o llamémosle más bien su lado "aburrido".
Ya dije; la magia no tiene que ocurrir
solo en el escenario,
también tiene que ocurrir en la gestión.
Uno tiene que saber:
cuanto gana, cuanto gasta,
uno tiene que sentarse a planificar
a corto, a mediano y a largo plazo.
Producir un espectáculo no solo implica
pensar en lo que pasa en el escenario,
el trabajo del artista no solo ocurre
frente al público.
En este camino como emprendedor,
como artista,
he descubierto estos tres pasos
que son fundamentales
y que quiero compartir hoy con Uds.:
Soñar, pensar y visualizar,
¿Dónde quiero estar? ¿Qué quiero hacer?
Como artista, como emprendedor,
como empresario.
Arriesgar,
salir de la zona de confort
para probar nuestras tesis,
nuestras teorías, nuestras ideas
lanzarte a demostrarle
a los demás tu convicción,
demostrarles tu amor,
y tu fe en lo que haces.
Y tres: Trabajar.
Trabajar mucho, mucho, mucho
utilizando tus sueños como una brújula
y tus riesgos como un motivador constante.
Y entonces, ¿Se van a animar?
Gracias
(Aplausos)